you know I like them all and I go back
to places that I worked on 10 or 20
years ago I haven't been for the last 10
years I play this is really nice you
know that it's like a long-lost relative
and you visit again but I guess a place
which stands out probably as a getty
center because I go up there and I see
how all the trees that I planted have
grown how the place is but sure how it
feels like it's been there for a long
time and yet people walk you around
looking at everything as though it's
Brad know it's an extraordinary place it
still gets huge numbers of visitors that
come not only for the exhibitions but
for the amazing library that's there and
for the environment the gardens the
relationship of the interior spaces to
exterior spaces moving through people
love it going there and I love going
there myself
nothing comes to mind
you